speaking of the four-day work week to
attract other workers here's another
story so what are employers doing to
attract workers basically we talked
about the global supply chain global uh
people not working um
all that fun stuff basically um the
global labor shortage sorry and uh what
are you doing to attract
employees so you know there's higher pay
flexible schedules remote uh access you
know work from home four day work weeks
extra vacation time some people are
paying for your colleges some employers
but get this get this when i saw this i
was like holy [ __ ]
now
some companies are so desperate to fill
jobs they're getting rid of drug tests
yo that dude who's smoking up all day in
his car oh good buddy we need you get to
work yeah yeah he can what what can
those hands do buddy let's do those
hands do exactly get in here companies
are so desperate to fill
jobs that they're basically saying
i'd smoke all the weed you want no more
drug tests come to work baby we need you
fun fact
ten percent of employers worldwide
messages in america worldwide are said
that they're eliminating job screenings
or drug tests in order to attract
and retain talent they're basically
saying do whatever you want in your free
time just please come to work just
please drug test no drug we don't give a
[ __ ] just come on it and that's what's
happening right across the world 10 of
employers
so
the old do what you want in your free
time but just come to work thing so they
interviewed an attorney who basically
lost out on a job because of a failed
drug test due to that
sticky green this is a weed because a
weed i think they should test for other
things like smoke pot i don't give a
[ __ ] just don't work don't smoke and
work or anything like that like if
you're shooting something up bro right
and you're gonna come into work all like
weird
[Laughter]
like that one guy who had to leave here
basically this attorney who basically
failed his job
um due to the
drug test due to the marijuana use he
says you know it's archaic society has
caught up to the reality that smoking
weed on your own time people don't care
about that we need laws and policies to
stop putting people out of a job for
petty reasons and putting people back to
work i agree with homing yeah he's a
lawyer i'm not going to disagree with
this guy look he's have i smoked to join
my life you betcha
am i smoking weed and coming to work no
not so much yeah but if you're if you're
if you're an employer and you're like
dude we need some freaking talent who
gives a [ __ ] if harry over here is
blazing on the weekends i don't care
yeah just come to work please
right i mean exactly no i mean if you're
popping pills at work and you're doing
some you're shooting up you're snorting
lines like back in the day or wall
street you know the wolf of wall street
that might be a problem
that's the thing
it's like it's where do you cut it off
it becomes a problem yes like if you're
doing that but you're still like number
one sales guy in the office and you're
getting [ __ ] done
like i'm concerned for your health but i
also like the money i really like the
numbers you're putting up there yeah
jorge whatever you're doing
keep it up keep it up smoke a joint do a
line i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care shout out to seinfeld
um anyway i fully agree right so no drug
test drug test i don't care let's get
people back to work so if that's
something that you're doing these perks
these days that's part of it
more power to you basically what's
happening
if
if you see what's going on right though
you know the four day work weeks
flexible work more vacation
please work no drug tests basically the
modern corporate work is just trying to
be cool dude party when you want you
know dr do your drugs four days a week
we're good baby just come to work please
we cool we cool working this we're in
the pool office you ain't cool unless
you pee your pants at work
shout out to adam sandler yeah yeah
that's right that's right yeah yeah
that's right
that's right anyway
so
and then there's this story right
speaking of trying to be cool you know
let me do what i want there's this story
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken